[Music]
[Music]
nice all week it'll probably rain all
weekend no it's gonna be beautiful
I'm gonna give you six strokes and still
take all your money
leave me out guys had a bad week and I'm
just gonna rest huh come on George have
been at least well tell you the truth
I've been taking a Sunday oh you're
getting to be an old man ah getting to
be an old man huh I don't know
maybe it's true and feeling blah
evening mrs. green well all weekend to
do just what I want to do nah misery
[Music]
unless Ethel's got one of her lists
again well it won't take long to find
out hmm
after dinner George I was thinking there
are a few things I'd like well why don't
we wait until after dinner a rest gonna
take the weekend off on four
but-but-but-but hi hey hey is this gonna
work
uh sure if you work it right a delayed
reverse strong side sweet four five
threes how does he flung ah damn Wow
George fumble ready pass the duck to
your father dear what is the matter with
you Joe nothing I are slipped I feel
fine
I've been making a list George we've got
a busy weekend it's going to be
split-second timing now while I'm doing
the dishes you run right around the
corner to the heart
[Music]
[Applause]
well why didn't you say something about
it you used to enjoy working around the
house I do well you ought to go see a
doctor today I'm not sick
gotta go you're toast got a hurry kind
of slowed down boy it's been hanging on
planets Monday got a chance to take it
easy why don't you keep these mr. Brown
I never get headaches
oh no no just just two's all I need oh
look go ahead and keep them
my grandmother's got arthritis and she
takes them all the time I'll see you
arthritis so I think maybe I'm getting a
touch of arthritis let's have a look I
know you're busy and I didn't make an
appointment
hello's have been bothering it mm-hmm
well a few months off and on in the
morning when you get out of here say huh
yeah do usually ah hellos take two go
away not long taking aspirin yes yeah
yes good get dressed
hmm arthritis is from the Greek Garth
Ron joint itis inflammation at the
Genesis can be metabolic infectious
trauma to Jenna congenital or obscure
differential diagnosis determines
prognosis and optimum therapeutics a
symptomatic relief is advisable
initially radical pharmacology is
contraindicated mitigation can be
achieved by salicylates aspirin doc
that's over my head I see well let's see
make an appointment next time okay at
Tuesday two weeks we'll make some tests
and really get into it
Oh miss furball give mr. brown diet
three please see you two weeks George
here you are mr. brown
yeah Here I am Thanks aspirin and a diet
a lot of big words
they don't know what to do about
arthritis well he seemed to know a lot
about it did he do me any good huh well
what else is there
does anybody know what to do just press
T your triceps press t get serious well
you don't knock it till you try it
yeah good step fringo fix it that's good
for a yeah yeah complete rest do
absolutely nothing
can I try ice packs why don't you start
lifted weights aspirin uh opium yoga
I think it's all in your mind huh
psychosom man now look buddy I know with
my arm hurt take it easy just an opinion
who asked me thought you did everybody's
got an opinion even Ethel go back to the
doctor she said what cool take to Aspen
and keep your chin up
well if it doesn't get any worse I'll be
okay doll that dirty what it dull
fireable what you doing in the dark I'm
just thinking honey can you fix my
puppet sure thank you hmm George for
heaven's sake go away don't slam the
door
George Brown come in it's been a while
yeah well I missed the appointment it it
wasn't bothering me at the time and
remission of simply hold it hold it doc
there are enough words I don't
understand around here already I see
anyway the elbows worse hands are
beginning to get stiff and the knuckles
you know know now what's going on miss
furball no calls please well let's see
you were easily fatigued yeah and you
regularly woke up stiff and sore yeah
and your elbow and now your knuckles are
inflamed and painful that's me I got
arthritis well it's not that simple the
word arthritis covers all the disorders
that affect the joints of the body
they've been around since the year one
waking every generation of mankind
gradually we learned that there are
dozens of really different disorders
that show up in the joints so for
somebody who is regularly stiff and sore
someplace here's the first question just
what have I got okay that's my question
well I can give you a quick opinion
George but we'll make some tests to be
sure there are a lot of possibilities
here's the most familiar type
osteoarthritis right
this is the one that makes most people
think arthritis is an old-folks disease
here's what happens a joint has let's
say a normal shape and works beautifully
because of osteoarthritis is a change in
that shape
little by little cartilage deteriorates
in the lining and new bone grows around
the edges many things seem to be able to
start this remodeling so even though it
seems to be connected just with the wear
and tear of a lifetime well that isn't
the whole story even in a young person
osteoarthritis can begin if a joint is
under constant strain like tennis elbow
or housemaids knee our housewife's jaw
not usually hey anyway many people
technically have osteoarthritis and
don't even know it because it begins
slowly and only a few joints and doesn't
get inflamed it's not usually as serious
as say gout gout that's that funny thing
isn't it well here's the traditional
picture the trouble is the traditional
picture is wrong you can live very
sensibly and still have gout it's a
metabolic disease sorry in other words
the body's chemistry is out of balance
there's too much of one chemical uric
acid and little crystals form in the
joint linings often right here as
suddenly there's an attack and it's not
funny it causes some terrific pain but
we've got some very reliable drugs to
stop attacks and if we know someone has
gout we can even prevent them with drugs
that control the uric acid and restore
the chemical balance then there's
rheumatoid arthritis it's really more
than a local joint disorder it spreads
in flames a number of joints in the body
affects the general health some doctors
think it's an infectious disease caused
by an agent like a germ or virus so
we're trying to find out who he is
there's another theory that this agent
is responsible only for the first step
of a more complex process the theory is
that normal cells in and around a joint
are changed by this agent just enough to
make them strangers to the body's
defense forces in the bloodstream so the
defenders tricked by the change of
uniform attacked them like they would an
invader from outside there's a lot of
research going on in these theories and
others - all of it's aimed at
understanding the causes of the disease
so we can get a cure but for now I'm
afraid the picture isn't exactly clear
have I got it I can't say yet but it's
possible one of those rare things here
know about three or four million cases
in the country all together all types of
arthritis over 16 million no kidding
16 million and all of us are stumbling
around gulping aspirin and hurting like
the devil there's got to be a cure
somebody wants to found something if you
insist on believing that let me let me
show you just what you're in for
you won't need much money to begin with
you can start with nice simple thing
like a copper bracelet maybe a warm
watch band spend only 15 minutes a day
with the electromagnetic vitalizer then
try a little local vibrator graduate to
the heavy-duty model forget your pain
under the
amazing spectra Nick beer a take your
pick of a hundred fantastic miraculous
brand-new time-tested formulas or go sit
in the health of old uranium mine doc
you don't think I'd fall for all that
lots of people do George it's a 300
million dollar business Wow
whoa what about those people who say
they've been cured testimonials
arthritis is a screwy disease erratic
sometimes the symptoms will just stop
for a few weeks a few years and if you
were using moose grease about that time
you'd think it was a miracle drug but
then some morning you'll wake up and
find you've spent years here and your
pain is back now worse and you're
getting crippled doc you're not making
my day you know what I mean well George
now wait a minute I come in here you
tell me I've got it it's going to get
worse I might be a [ __ ] and nothing's
gonna help sit down a minute George
hard core there are two false notions
about arthritis one is there's a quick
cure but there's another there's nothing
to do but suffer now that's false - and
dangerous because just about the worst
thing you can do about arthritis is
nothing why do you sit there feeling
sorry for yourself it's getting worse
and that's just what you want to prevent
what can I do where do you make up your
mind you've got a chronic disease you're
gonna have to deal with it for a long
time maybe all your life but we've
learned a lot that can help you well
fill me in you're already using one
thing aspirin oh well now don't
underrate it because it's common with
the dose increase to high level it's
pretty powerful it reduces pain and
swelling and inflammation it's the basic
drug as long as it does the job later if
we need them there are some even more
powerful drugs I knew there must be
something yes but it's not that easy
these drugs steroids gold affect each
case differently it might take a while
to judge the success of a drug and there
can be some bad side effects so we begin
conservatively advanced
slowly and watch carefully another thing
we watch is what you eat there was
nothing special about that diet you gave
me no no gimmicks just good nutrition
and proper weight to give those bones a
fighting chance
now you can't handle arthritis just by
putting the right things in your mouth
there's physical medicine in the program
too here's the theory behind it if a
sore joint is favored too much if you
retire it the surrounding muscles get
weaker and the whole thing drifts apart
in time the space in the joint gets
filled in with tissue and when that
hardens your crippled so I've got to
keep it working right the motto is if
you can do yeah well that's my wife's
motto too I'm pretty active good but
don't just grit your teeth and go on
you've got to keep the pain and
inflammation down good thought the one
thing that helps is he yeah I noticed
that okay dry heat wet heat special
treatments like hot paraffin baths each
has its advantages and they do more than
sooth pain they make a physical therapy
routine easier and more helpful suppose
a certain set of muscles needs toning up
the routines are tailored to accomplish
that or if the joint is over strained
there are all sorts of devices designed
to rest it or reinforce it so there's a
lot we can do the best program for an
individual takes cooperation the patient
is doctor and his family each has a part
but the patient is the key if he lets
himself feel like an invalid his
arthritis can make him one but if he
starts a treatment program early and
sticks to it arthritis won't keep him
from leading a pretty normal life active
satisfying what do you think George I
think he should keep his head down and I
guess I'll keep mine up let's make these
tests you know I don't keep mine down
all the time either and the grips
terrible
about this physical-therapy I got some
muscles to keep forgetting I'm trying to
play golf you know even mrs. green
George Browns had a hard time getting to
know what he needed to know about
arthritis it took him a year to learn
what you just learned in 15 minutes now
if you'll just keep the facts straight
it could save a lot of time and a lot of
pain if you should ever happen to become
one of those 16 million Americans who
have arthritis
[Music]